[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in the hall of famer charlie
steiner 17 seasons as the dodgers
play by play voice on am570 la sports
chaz good to have you back
what was the atmosphere like there the
last two nights it was
fun it was electric uh the first game
the fans were angry i mean there was an
open hostility
and then when they got down 3-0 and we
had more inflatable trash cans than i'd
ever seen in my life
and we had usually when there's a home
run a ball is
thrown back onto the field there were
foul balls
that were thrown back onto the field so
the first game it was a little bit
dicey last night for a change it was in
fact the players
and their bats that did most of the
talking so
both of the nights were dramatic and
theatrical last night in hollywood where
they always strive for a happy ending at
long last there was
but also i wonder if winning a world
series
has defused this just a little bit for
dodger fans
no okay no all right
but it was fascinating because
one of the beauties of working at
dodger stadium it's a home field
advantage it's you know a visually
spectacular ballpark
the sun sets the san gabriel mountains
are off in the distance and you have 52
000 each of the first two nights the
first night there was this air of
trepidation
and after being shut out in the first
game
last night max scherzer shows up
have gun will travel he might have been
paladin
and and the way he came out and did his
business the dodgers were in desperate
need of a win they were feeling
awful about the previous night
and then there was this sense of okay
now it's the
player's turn to uh
speak their vengeance and they did so
with their bats
and the crowd was a little well i can't
say subdued a little more gentlemanly
last night than they were in the first
night but there were two terrific
theatrical games between two terrific
teams
who of course met in the world series
and 17
so it was great great theater and and
and scherzer just turned in one of those
performances
so that you if you ever needed reminding
of how
great this guy is and how he is able to
withstand
and even embrace the pressure of the
moment it was a
it was a brilliant athletic theatrical
production last night
how do you think history will treat the
astros not well
i think at the end of the day they will
always have that scarlet letter
um and in this town now
i don't know if it's 1 and 1a or they're
just
tied for first between altuve and
carrasco
the booze were genuine they were
visceral
uh the other guys they were politely
booed because they're the other team
but those two guys they really got it
and and last night when uh scherzer
began the game by striking out altuve
arch
enemy number one out here the place went
crackers and that was the scene that was
the feel that was the vibe throughout
the night it was
great great theater what are the dodgers
issues right now they have to figure out
when kershaw gets back
they have to solidify their bullpen some
you know they still haven't gotten trey
turner to
arrive as yet but last night for
instance dan
scherzer comes back after his
spectacular performance and it was you
know
it was hotel quality as as kennywood
said
uh he comes back to the dugout and he is
greeted by
clayton kershaw mookie betts
albert pujold's i mean it was a
star-studded attraction greeting him and
in all the years i've been doing it and
i've been working with rick monday now
for 17 years
we were talking about i had never seen a
pitcher
receive a curtain call usually when he
is finished he goes into the dugout gets
his high fives goes about his business
last night it was a curtain call he was
pushed out by whoever
oh it just happened to be clayton
kershaw it was one of those
magical moments i swear i don't ever
remember a pitcher
after a performance after coming out of
the game then getting a curtain call so
it
it really was a magical electric
charismatic moment last night what uh
can you sum up what's going on with cody
bellinger
no he really is
lost you know he's still getting over a
shoulder
issue and so that may be part of it
uh but right now he is in one of those
slumps
nobody ever wants to be in he's uh
he's dead last for anybody who's got at
least 200 ad bats he's hitting a buck
60 something um and you know it's been a
soft
160 something you know how this is
eventually going to play out
don't know uh but one of the things
about
bellinger uh he may not be hitting much
but he's still as good a defender in
center field right field or first base
as there is so he does he does bring a a
palpable strength to the club right now
it just
isn't with his back it's great to catch
up with you charlie hope you're well
i'm doing great you know they still
haven't caught up to me apparently i
haven't caught up to you either
uh somebody asked about the andrew shue
sportscenter commercial where we traded
you from sportscenter to melrose place
yep uh i i asked you this one question
where is he now how that trade worked
out
i like it i like that where did you
shoot that commercial
where you're the pool boy we flew out
to california we flew out onto the set
and when we did i don't know it was
1990ish and
melrose place was a big deal and i
remember getting out there
and the women on the set
had no idea who the hell i was they had
no clue
the guys all they wanted to do is talk
sports
and then they put me in that getup and
it was the first and only time
i you know i i had a shemata on my head
i had you know my arms and
i'm bobby the f pool boy and
i had no idea it would turn out the way
it did
we actually went on site to do a sports
center commercial that's how long ago
and how much fun it was
ago and people forget when we first
started
and i remember going to john wall she
was our boss and i said why don't we
promote sportscenter we promote every
other show we don't promote sportscenter
he goes well we don't have to and
he said you know let me see
let me see and then he brought in wyden
kennedy and then they followed us around
and then wyden kennedy people who were
the geniuses behind it
said uh hey we can't get any athletes
because we don't pay for
anybody to do these commercials and i
reached out to grant hill and jason kidd
and i said look you don't get paid but
you get your own commercial
and grant hill played the piano in the
lobby jason kidd came in in
a helicopter to drop off his highlight
tape while he's in his
mavs uniform after that everybody wanted
their commercial and you know we were we
were forever indebted to grant hill and
jason kidd
you uh did you have one of those was
there one other moment that stood out
uh as far as doing those with you well
for me i guess the one that still has
legs and it's crazy is now what 30 years
almost
um follow me to freedom
the y2k the y2k
and i guess evander come looking for me
come get your whoopin
the worst part when that spot first came
out
uh you know again you and i were at a
time when we didn't
know or realize espn was about to become
what it would eventually become
uh then all of a sudden these
commercials took place
i'd be walking through an airport and
i'd have like some seven-year-old kid
come up to me to be all excited and said
come get your whooping you know and it's
like
come on and that's when i realized these
these commercials were to something yeah
look you
and i and all of us who were there then
going through that evolution
bordering on revolution espn plopping
onto the scene
and then those spots the irony was as
you recall we
have nice christmas parties where a
couple of hundred people would show up
and everybody knew one another
and by the end of the time we would go
to our own parties and we have no idea
who they were who were there and they
wanted autographs from
yeah uh and at this one party
steve bornstein is uh talk and it's
late at night so picture the ambiance
espn president steve yes and we were all
sufficiently liquored up at two in the
morning
and and bornstein says to me the late
john
saunders and boomer he said
in a perfect world sportscenter would be
anchored by
monkeys and clowns and all we
really need is the espn logo behind us
and then he says after another belt of
some hooch
he points at me and saunders and and
boomer and he said
but you you and you have screwed up our
plan
and within several weeks you know
everybody had this notion of maybe we
could do something to promote
us and again they were trying to
submerge our personalities initially
now all of a sudden the commercials come
out and it changed only everything
well steve bornstein is the author of
the famous quote
where he called me at lunch
while he wanted me to sign an extension
you're just
bleeping talent using the f-word
so we're having lunch and he says
you're just bleeping talent and that's a
good opening gambit
yeah yeah and hey we want you to sign
an extension okay so
make up your mind i'm just effing talent
or
hey we want you to stay for a little
while and
i signed the extension yeah i i had 14
years there how many do you have
18 all right yeah so look it was a great
run while it was and here we are and
you know one of the things i was
thinking about the other night dan
watching
kenny and rich doing the olympic stuff
on peacock
it was like a sports center reunion
you know sportscenter 20 years later and
i
i gotta tell you i don't know about you
i felt so proud
especially with mike who's anchoring the
whole shooting match
kenny being kenny and rich b and rich
it reminded me
of how good we were then a lot of
challenges how good they are now
yeah a lot of town and tarico came in he
was just a kid
and they weren't like yeah get in get in
line and
kenny was the guy who was covering tonya
harding in seattle
and it's like well so we brought them in
and
hell they brought me and i had no
television talent but somehow
they put this thing together and
for all the years you've been doing
you've been doing all the years i've
been doing what i'm doing
in that heyday that was about as much
fun as i ever had in my career i mean
there we were ice station zebra aka
bristol
um just doing what we did and did it
reasonably well
and uh left little very little blood on
the floor
it's good to catch up with you charlie
and uh thanks for joining us as always
dan good to see you thanks buddy that's
uh charlie steiner 17 years
dodgers radio play-by-play voice on our
great affiliate am 570
la sports and a member of the national
radio hall of fame